well afghans are attempting to resume
their lives under the new taliban ruled
of course the country faces major
economic challenges the unemployment is
running high and some of those with jobs
say they are not being paid women have
been promised to be able to return to
work and their studies but some local
leaders say the taliban won't change
their hardline approach
some things never change
traffic in kabul still a mess
other things do and they will under
taliban rule
whether it's the taxi drivers
the market traders
the traffic police
are their mothers sisters and daughters
everyone is wondering the same thing
what now
there are no jobs that is why the people
are worried they should try to create
jobs and open the floor for education
there is no education or jobs for the
time being
[Music]
about the withdrawal of the foreigners
nobody wants foreigners in the country
we would like to have our own people not
foreigners
but having jobs is very important if
there are no jobs at all
educated people will leave the country
and go abroad
in kandahar the spiritual home of the
taliban there appeared not a hint of
apprehension
as crowds and fighters celebrated their
victory with the weapons that brought it
to them
but elsewhere taliban commanders are now
getting to grips with the job of
governing
the new mayor of mazari sharif warned
that the hardline group would not soften
there's no difference between the
previous government and our government
now
about the women it's the same islamic
rules and way they should wear the hijab
they can continue their education they
can go to work this is our message to
all the women
the mixed messages coming from their new
leaders have left many here anxious
about what shape taliban rule will take
and what it will mean for future
generations
[Music]